[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue son plateau d'
interdit d'interdire pour une émission
consacrée toute entière à emmanuel todd
et à son nouveau livre oursons telle une
esquisse de l'histoire des femmes un
livre qui a déjà fait couler beaucoup
d'encre car il s'agit d'une réponse à
l'idéologie féministe actuelle qui nous
explique que le patriarcat la domination
masculine universelle a été le moteur
d'une violence in été rompues à l'égard
des femmes et cela depuis toujours et
bien d'après emmanuel todd historiens
anthropologues spécialiste des
structures familiales ça ne s'est pas du
tout passé comme ça vous allez nous vous
raconter pourquoi mais d'abord voici
l'image que vous avez choisi pour
symboliser notre époque c'est un
retraité dans un isoloir l'une des
choses qui me préoccupe beaucoup quand
même en tant que citoyens attachés à la
démocratie libérale c'est le poids pris
par la partie âgées du corps électoral
qui semble sur le point de paralyser les
démocraties occidentales puisque
maintenant les gens qui votent qui ont
le pouvoir en fait le centre de gravité
du poids électoral s'est détaché
de la population active mais il pourrait
vous répondre c'est pas de notre faute
c'est la faute du reste de la population
qui se déplacent moins que nous non non
je dis rien d'emma statistiques c'est
dramatique parce que
le vieillissement de la population et le
résultat de succès prodigieux
pour l'allongement de la vie humaine
donc c'était une bonne chose mais ça
produit c'est à des effets pervers si on
peut dire d'une chose bonne ça produit
de même que la contraception est une
bonne chose qui a réduit le nombre des
naissances
c'est toutes ces bonnes choses ont
abouti à ce résultat
totalement inattendu qui aura duré que
prévu mais qu'il n'a pas été quand on a
mis en place la démocratie la sécurité
sociale etc d'un vieillissement
prodigieux la population qui touchent à
des degrés divers tous les pays
plus des pays comme l'allemagne et le
japon où l'italie que la france
l'angleterre où les états unis mais
parce que les états unis aussi le pays
leaders dont qui a fait nos veines de
vieillissement du corps électoral mais
qu'on pourrait suivre dans tous les
domaines donc en fait l'un de mes
projets de recherche actuellement
c'est par exemple le gâtisme en
politique internationale en pensant aux
états unis oui parce que à la fois ils
se déplacent plus pour aller voter non
plus ils sont plus nombreux de faisant
même si les autres si elle est de toute
façon on peut faire comprendre les
choses d'une façon très simple c'est à
dire que pas par exemple les gens sont
conscients du fait que la population
vieillit qui a des problèmes de retraite
et cetera mais donc on a des vieux qui
sont à la retraite et qui sont
absolument emballé par le fait de
diminuer les retraites des types qui
vont suivre qui sont en train de
travailler nos cadeaux et mais en fait
la question est complètement sérieuse
c'est quand des choses se passent comme
ça est ce qu'on peut dire qu'on est
toujours en démocratie c'est la
philosophie politique qui a spéculé sur
la démocratie représentative à laquelle
je suis très attaché avait en tête à un
citoyen d'âge médian de 25 30 ans mais
pas plus de 50 ans et à ce moment là on
devrait se poser la question est ce que
du temps où les femmes ne pouvaient pas
voter en france par exemple jusqu'en
1944 est-ce qu'on était bien mais comme
démocratie donc on n'était pas au sens
plan démocratie je dirais que
l'intégration des femmes au corps
électoral
n'a pas posé ce genre de problème je
pense que l'irruption des femmes au
coeur de la vie sociale a été une
excellente chose mais qu'elle ait eu
aussi à sa manière des effets
secondaires a complètement positif qu'on
n'avait pas anticipé et corps dont on va
parler dans cette émission est le média
le taux d'alors dans ou en sont elles
unissent qu'une une esquisse de
l'histoire des femmes qui vient donc de
paraître aux éditions du seuil vous
retracer l'évolution des relations entre
les deux sexes depuis les origines
d'homo sapiens jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est
à dire au féminisme actuelle avec sa
conception antagonistes des rapports
entre hommes et femmes les hommes
auraient toujours dominer les femmes
partout sur la planète il les aurait a
servi brimé enfermé violenté chosifié et
cela depuis toujours une conception avec
laquelle l'historien l'anthropologue
emmanuel todd le spécialiste des
structures familiales n'est pas du tout
d'accord c'est d'abord c'est un élément
bon sens alors de toute façon quand on
reconstitue l'histoire de la famille
humaine ce que j'ai fait dans plusieurs
livres antérieurs déjà ce qu'on trouve à
l'autre de l'humanité c'est une famille
nucléaire c'est une famille conjugal
avec ses enfants
encastré dans un groupe de parenté ou
les parents du côté de la mère et du
côté du père ont d importance égale vous
parlez des chasseurs cueilleurs été
pendant deux cents mille ans à peu près
100 200 mille trois cent mille c'est en
débat actuellement
et dans danser
ce type de communauté il y a une ce que
j'appelle une patrie de bin ans en
particulier pour ce qu'il s'agit du
collectif c'est qu'il s'agisse de la
guerre d'agression ou de protection
contre des groupes extérieurs ou contre
drize des animaux une prédominance des
hommes dans les activités de
distribution collective de chasse mais à
la base au delà de ça il ya
nécessairement une solidarité
fondamentale entre hommes et femmes le
problème du chasseur cueilleur c'est pas
un problème d'égalité et de liberté
théorique dans un monde sûr développer
le problème du chasseur cueilleur ces
deux survivre et de se reproduire et
donc on ne peut pas concevoir de succès
initial de l'espèce humaine sans un
minimum une prédominance de la monogamie
avec un peu de polygamie ou de
polyandrie si nécessaire
son job puis jean fabre etc mais hors de
l'hypothèse d'une fondamentale
solidarité du couple on ne pourrait pas
comprendre comme en l'espèce humaine
humaine a réussi à couvrir la planète
voyez c'est juste c'est un truc de bon
sens lorsqu'il dresse et qu'ensuite dans
l'histoire après l'invention de
l'agriculture
particulièrement les hommes ont élargi
je pourrais dire lors leurs espaces de
pouvoir
profitant je ne sais pas leur force
physique
du fait que les femmes étaient plus par
définition paralysées par leur fonction
maternelle et autres et on peut décrire
à la suite de l'invention l'agriculture
à partir de la mésopotamie de la chine
de l'afrique de l'ouest un processus de
ce que j'appelle patrie linéarisation
sert de montée en puissance
d'une sorte de collectif masculin qui
s'est étendue vers la périphérie de
l'eurasie mais qui pour l'essentiel n'a
évidemment pas à pain les amériques et
puis qui n'a pas atteint notre occident
à nous notre extrême occident c'est à
dire la france la scandinavie
les anglais donc puis les états unis met
donc à cette histoire différencier et
appliquée à tout ça le mot de patriarcat
qui est quand même si on réfléchit deux
minutes super violent en plus dans le
patriarcat il n'y a pas que l'idée de
domination masculine ja je voudrais pas
avoir être un obsédé achir autocratie
mais il ya aussi l'idée de vieillesse
c'est le vieux malins qui est quand même
visé par la notion de patriarcat
subliminalement et son que n'ont pas
trait dominant ce
qui contraint d'exploser à l'ouest absil
banques et qu'on va regarder dans les
détails mais je vais m'arrêter sur parce
que vous distinguer trois des trois
vagues du féminisme la première vague
c'étaient les chiffrages est au tournant
du 20e siècle ça nous vient de
grande-bretagne
la revendication c'est l'égalité elles
veulent le droit de vote je peux dire
tout de suite pourquoi réussir ça s'est
passé plutôt en grande bretagne mais
allez gilles passé contrairement à ce
compte maintenant on perçoit les pays
protestants comme extrêmement avancé
libéraux féministes etc mais la vérité
c'est ce que j'ai découvert en tradant
sur ce sujet c'est que le protestantisme
était très hostile aux femmes je dirais
à fermer les monastères dont les
monastères féminin une femme devait être
vraiment soumise aux affaires familiales
le protestantisme a été une véritable
tentative patriarcale et donc la
précocité et la virulence de féminisme
anglo américain pays protestants quand
même ou scandinaves même vient de ce que
tentatives patriarcal on peut le dire
avait été plaqué et a raté d'ailleurs
plaqué sur une société où les rapports
entre hommes et femmes étaient plutôt
égalitaire et donc cette source
d'émancipation mais c'est pas du tout
parce que les états unis ou l'angleterre
était comment dire plus fédéraliste en
soin de dire je serai capable de
soutenir maintenant que la france
catholique puis républicains malgré
l'absence du droit de vote était dans
ses tréfonds plus décontracté vis-à-vis
des femmes et on va le voir parce que
vous allez nous le raconter en détail
après cette première vague qui demande
de droit de vote il ya la deuxième vague
du féminisme ou alors la base et sur la
sexualité qui commence alors elle aux
états unis et par grande bretagne et qui
commence avec l'invention de la pilule
en 1961 que la vie la france aura en 67
et puis qui culmine avec le droit à
l'avortement qui arrive au début des
années 70 ça c'est la sexualité et puis
là il ya la troisième vague qui elle
vient de ce que je suis un peu déçu de
ne pas voir la photo de ma grand mère
henriette 10 ans avait signé le
manifeste des 343
là on voit simone de beauvoir
effectivement là on est au moment où la
revendications portent sur la sexualité
la troisième vague celle laquelle on a
affaire aujourd'hui elle elle vient de
suède plus tôt et elle elle repose sur
l'identité 1 d'après ce que vous dites
c'est c'est on va repenser les rapports
la nature plus et se doit son talent et
partir à mon loin mais les américains
sont un peu là dedans quand même soirée
là dedans et les anglais enfin t on
remarque que les anglais les appeler
protestants ont simplement laissé des
obsessions de profession
est donc là on en est là c'est on va
revenir sur les rapports entre les
hommes et les femmes et on commence à
parler patriarcat ce dont ne parlait pas
les chiffrages est par exemple non mais
le mot le mot patriat bas à l'époque des
suffrages est le mot patriarcat existait
en anthropologie mais il désignait la
famille russe
la famille arabe la famille chinois cd
vaste système patrie nerfs mais personne
n'aurait eu l'idée de parler de
patriarcat pour
frédéric le play n'aurait pas osé parler
de patriat est là pour les gaulois
c'est
[Musique]
pourquoi en france on en aurait pas eu
l'idée d'après ce que vous dites c'est
qu'au fond nous sommes les héritiers
directs des des chasseurs cueilleurs les
chaises bancales york vous décriviez
tout à l'heure donc des petits groupes à
l'intérieur desquels il ya des couples
avec des enfants est une division du
travail qui fonctionne qui est très
efficace solidaire où l'homme va la
chasse et la femme fait la cueillette
parfois les hommes et les enfants quand
même et les ensembles bien trop grands
ducs ont un peu de temps dans son église
et laissez donc les femmes et les
enfants font la cueillette parfois les
hommes se joignent aux femmes et aux
enfants mais jamais les femmes ne vont à
la chasse en tout cas pas pour les gros
animaux est ce que vous dites c'est que
on partageait le produit de la chasse
entre eux tous les ménages du groupe en
revanche on ne partageait pas la
cueillette et c'était pour ça là vous
allez directement à la teste ce qui est
pour moi la thèse la plus importante est
là peut-être la plus discutable de
livres je reste un chercheur c'est à
dire ces sept cette constatation de ce
que
dans à l'origine de l'homme il y à une
fixation du collectif sur les hommes et
de l'individualisme familiale sur les
femmes et je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher
d'émettre l'hypothèse que dans la mesure
où deux des choses mais plus importante
qu'on vient de vivre
en occident c'est l'émancipation des
femmes et la désintégration de la
capacité d'action collective dont le néo
libéralisme ou l'ultra libéralisme
économique n'est qu'un aspect est ce que
il n'y aurait pas
un rapport entre cette irruption des
femmes au coeur de la vie sociale dont
je dis dans le livre qu'elle a toutes
sortes de bons aspects comme
l'effondrement du racisme de
l'homophobie
toutes ces lubies mme masculine est ce
que cette émancipation des femmes
n'expliquerait pas pour une part
l'espèce de coups de blues ou qu'on a au
niveau de l'action collective
c'est pas c'est pas simplement l'action
c'est la capacité à se penser collective
avec l'effondrement 10 des nations des
choses comme ça cette division du
travail
encore une fois telle que vous la
décrivez tout ça se passe bien il n'y a
pas d'histoire de domination on
collabore parce que c'est la garantie de
la survie de l'espèce c'est c'est ce
couple en or l'homme et la femme qui a
fait que les enfants ont pu ont pu
grandir et faire des enfants à leur tour
etc mais il faut quand même dire quand
on fait l'histoire de très longue durée
d'abord quand on fait l'histoire de très
longue durée on ne passe pas son temps à
juger l'histoire et à se raconter que
l'histoire aurait dû être différentes
dans l'histoire elle a été ce qu'elle a
été mais il faut bien voir qu'une partie
du discours alors qu'il n'y ait pas de
malentendu l'émancipation des choses des
femmes est une chose formidable
moi je suis dans les générations bad sur
un boomer un vieux boomer et je crois
que les jeunes femmes d'aujourd'hui ne
se rendent pas compte à laquelle du
point auquel ma génération et elle
spontanément
féministe je dirais égalitaire mais je
crois qu'au stade actuel nous on avait
encore une vague conscience d'un passé
pauvre et difficile
voyez je fais partie des générations qui
bouffe est ce qu'on leur donnait à table
où on ne discutait pas eh oui nos
parents avec de la guerre il a connu la
guerre dont on nous bourre et de viande
parce que tout le monde avait été privé
de viande pendant la guerre j'ai donc
j'évite vécu dans le souvenir des
rutabagas j'avais su ce que cette année
voilà et quand même il faut bien se
rendre compte que une partie des débats
actuels ou le regain d'intérêt de
déformation pour le mot patriarcat c'est
quand même une idéologie d'enfants gâtés
qui a totalement perdu de vue ce
qu'était le problème fondamental
initiale de l'ue évitez la survie et la
reproduction et la survie et la
reproduction et la survie
avec l'élément tragique que cette
attitude d'enfant gâté intervient au
moment finalement où le niveau de vie
est en train de s'effondrer
pour toutes sortes de raisons c'est ce
qu'on est en train de vivre dans les
pénuries les crises locaux vides etc les
gilles et jo des compagnies et qu'en
fait on va avoir besoin simplement son
sens je suis pas un partisan de
l'apocalypse mais on va avoir besoin de
se remonter les manches d'être un peu
solidaires et pensez simplement à mettre
en avant comme une priorité
je veux dire le conflit entre les sexes
amateurs d'une espèce dont la survie
revient le problème principal donc là le
couple est la clé de la survie de
l'espèce le coût pour la clé de
l'éducation des enfants mais au fait est
ce qu ont rendez compte de ce qu'on soit
forcé de dire ça maintenant c'est juste
extraordinaire mais ça n'est pas
l'asservissement de la femme qui désire
me sers voyez vous voyez c'est comme
quand au début du bouquin ce dernier
mois je suis rentré dans les théories du
genre jeu ces jours ci je suis accusé
d'avoir rien lui c'est que c'est vieux
c'est tout à fait faux j'en ai pas trop
parler par politesse parce que c'est
quand même d'un niveau intellectuel pas
terrible voilà mais c'est quand même
extraordinaire qu'un moment donné j'ai
dû me dire non c'est pas possible tout
ça ne va nulle part on ne peut pas
penser l'évolution sociale on ne peut
même pas pensé les différences aux
différences sociales entre les hommes et
les femmes sans la notion sexe par
rapport à laquelle en est donc le genre
cela et j'arrive à produire à me
chauffer tout seul dans la chaumière
bretonne en disant non non je vais faire
un saut épistémologie considérable je
vais définir comme femme tout être
humain capable or deux cas accidentel de
stérilité de porter un enfant et je
jouerai encore le monde dans lequel on
est pour en arriver à dire à se dire
qu'on est très audacieux en disant un
truc comme ça c'est ça l'idéologie ça
peut être mal vu effectivement mais donc
pour vous les français mais pas
seulement les français les scandinaves
les anglo américains
sont les les descendants des chasseurs
cueilleurs au sens où le statut de la
femme a toujours été élevé dans le
guitariste qui n'a pas toujours été le
cas ailleurs
il n'a il n'a pas été très abc donc si
on se place au coeur de l'histoire des
bad l'histoire la définition de
l'histoire c'est l'invention de
l'écriture donc les lieu d'invention de
l'écriture c'est la mésopotamie un peu
l'egypte sur les bords quand même
beaucoup l'egypte qui évolue de façon un
peu différente la chine est donc il
triture agriculture danse etc ah et puis
invention de forme familiale considérée
comme très moderne qui augmente la place
de l'homme et qui aboutissent au travers
des millénaires à un abaissement du
statut des femmes et puis diffusion de
ses formes tout autour de vous voyez ça
c'est l'exception et égyptienne ouais
vous chers les si vous comparez les
représentations féminines
inexistante d'ailleurs ou peu existantes
sauf les plus anciennes rames on parle
de la mésopotamie vous n'aurez pas ça la
femme égyptienne l'un des mystères de la
culture égyptienne c'est le respect des
femmes qui a persisté au travers des
millénaires mais prenons aussi en
réaction la mésopotamie une élément de
réaction des jeunes voilà je suis désolé
je ne pouvais pas m'empêcher de parler
quand j'étais en sixième dans mon le
beau livre d'histoire que
ben avait acheté mon père qui est sans
doute un livre qui est un peu l'origine
de ma vocation d'historien il y avait ce
genre de gravure et ge était secrètement
tombé amoureux d'une princesse
égyptienne donc je pense à mon regard
que vous nous dites signaux font
toujours la vie quand on prive d'un
simple quand on voit les femmes afghanes
ou exemple et on se dit en fait ça c'est
notre passé 20 jours ne dans nos parmi
nos ancêtres il ya eu des hommes qui ont
fait la même chose aux femmes vous nous
dites pas du tout non les les afghans
comme les russes d'une autre manière les
chinois les japonais
n'ont pas les mêmes structures
familiales et les allemands les
allemands ne sont pas passés par là même
évolution ils se sont crus plus me dire
qu'un rasoir au fond plus arcade mais
c'est à dire que si vous allez au plus
profond de l'histoire mésopotamienne
vous allez trouver des couples des
représentations de couple très solidaire
les offrandes aux dieux en les mecs ont
déjà une grosse barbe quand même temps
qu'un peu affirmée en termes de virilité
etc mais qui ressemble beaucoup dans
leur équilibre à des représentations
médiévales qu'on trouve en europe avec
des rapports disant égalitaire et puis
ça disparaît dans le temps les femmes
finissent par disparaître complètement
dans ces régions après l'arabisation
d'ailleurs plutôt que que l'islamisation
mais cette évolution
n'a pas eu lieu ailleurs est donc enfin
universel le passé le passé familial de
l'histoire humaine on le retrouve sur
toute la périphérie du globe donc va le
trouver dans les amériques on va le
trouver en scandinavie dans les îles
britanniques en france en espagne au
portugal au 6 mai et puis on va le
retrouver en asie du sud-est
et aux philippines et dans ces régions
mais au coeur vous allez voir divers
niveaux de diffusion d'une idéologie de
pratiques patrie nerfs qui est quand
même très variable parce qu'au coeur
vous allez avoir un maximum
d'abaissement le coeur ça va être je
dirai la même chose se dire le moyen
orient et l'inde du nord
et puis ça baisse en russie il ya ce
paradoxe d'une culture pâte linéaire
très bien typés c'est quand vous
regardez les familles de paysans russe
du 19e siècle on a des très beaux
recensement de grands domaines
c'est vraiment une architecture pas
traîné rhénan mais le ses récents
17e 18e certainement au xvième siècle la
famille russe peut être at elle encore
du p r
et le statut de la femme n'a pas été
vraiment très a baissé parce que deux
siècles pour abaisser le statut de la
femme son ereader c'est pas suffisant
alors ça explique une bonne partie de la
dynamique russe d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire en allemagne
ça l'allemagne a été touché par le
problème principal trineer alors l'une
des bizarreries une chose que je suis
pas arrivé complètement expliqué c'est
que la structure familiale allemande
c'est de l'image de primogéniture
masculine
en théorie et plus féministe que le
système communautaire russe mais il ya
des indicateurs qui semble suggérer que
le statut des femmes a été plus à
baisser en allemagne a aussi pour moi
c'est un domaine de recherche voyez la
seule façon de pouvoir de faire
comprendre je suis vraiment chercheurs
c'est pas de dire ce que j'ai trouvé
c'est d'exprimer mes doutes vous voyez
et donc il ya d'ailleurs parmi vous dit
vous vous posez d'ailleurs la question
de savoir que chi danser ces régions du
globe où tout à coup le statut de la
femme a été très abc peut parler du
monde arabe de la chine de l'inde du
nord de l'inde de l'afrique de l'ouest
et c'est un label taku qui avaient été
des grandes civilisations et qui tout à
coup se bloque et sont dépassés par leur
incident est ce que ça ne tient pas au
fait que tout à coup la moitié de leur
population les femmes ont vu leur statut
considérablement baissé oui mais ça ça
fait très longtemps ce avait créé au
début des années 80 un livre qui
montrait que la vitesse
d'alphabétisation des pays était
fonction du statut des femmes et que
plus le statut des femmes il y avait
d'autres variables mais plus le statut
des femmes était élevé plus la vitesse
de développement éducatif des pays était
rapide par exemple vous preniez l'inde
il ya un état au sud de l'inde le kerala
où il y avait des systèmes valliot
familiaux matrilinéaire un peu plus
compliqué je les décrire décrirais pas
où le taux de l'inde du nord est très
patrilinéaire ont contraint etc et le
taux d'alphabétisation au lendemain
matin vers 11h le taux de réalisation du
kerala était deux fois la moyenne
indienne oui donc donc à il ya un
rapport entre
je dirais un statut élevé de la femme
est une ville et vitesse de
développement des sociétés mais ça c'est
une chose que j'avais établi au début
des années 80 c'est bon ça c'est pour ça
que maintenant on me dit que je suis
contre le féminisme le début où j'habite
surtout surtout par des gens qui n'ont
pas lu ce livre où cette thèse est
rappelé c'est vraiment très drôle pour
résumer juste avant de faire une pause
pendant 105 200 mille ans il ya partout
sur le globe des chasseurs cueilleurs
avec une structure assez égalitaire une
collaboration dans le vin ou pl hommes
femmes une division du travail avec des
hommes avec très strict très stricte
avec des hommes donc qui s'occupe du
collectif
légère patrie dominance commandite des
femmes qui s'occupe plus
particulièrement de la famille toute
chose qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui vous
nous expliquer pourquoi certains et puis
après ça a évolué différemment et il ya
des régions du monde plutôt centre où le
statut de la femme va s'abaisser mais au
bout d'un à bout d'un certain temps et
et puis d'autres comme chez nous il ya
des millénaires des mille et des
millénaires de boulot voilà et chez nous
bah nous on est un peu les héritiers des
chasseurs cueilleurs donc le statut de
la femme est toujours resté assez élevé
on est les plus archaïques au fond on se
croit moderne alors que non on est
archaïque n'ont jamais évolué et
finalement
notre bonheur pour neutre c'est-à-dire
qu'on a pris aux régions du centre de
l'eurasie qui ont inventé l'agriculture
l'état l'écriture tda on a pris tout ce
qui avait de bien sauf l'abaissement du
statut de la femme et dont condé rester
performant en terme de développement ont
fait une pause et vous allez nous
expliquer la suite emmanuel todd
[Musique]
le patriarcat est il vraiment existé
dans un pays comme d'autres
ainsi que nous le disent les féministes
actuelle on n'est toujours avec emmanuel
todd qui publie en jouant sont elles une
esquisse de l'histoire des femmes aux
éditions du seuil vous nous avez
expliqué très bien la famille
universelle d'origine celle des
chasseurs cueilleurs et pourquoi ensuite
ça se passe différemment selon les
régions du globe mais en occident vous
fait bien la différence entre les pays
protestants et les pays catholiques vous
nous expliquer qu'au fond le
christianisme a participé de de
l'élévation du statut des femmes avec
l'instauration du mariage
les femmes
se marient avec leur consentement au
moins en théorie enfin il ya l'idée du
consentement et puis à l'idée qu' on ne
peut pas les quitter le divorce restera
interdite jusqu'au 19ème siècle donc
c'est un élévation du statut des femmes
le protestantisme en revanche il ya une
petite régression est ce que vous pouvez
nous l'expliquer oui c'est un peu quand
on lit le protestantisme et par
d'allemagne qui est quand même un par
les techniques pour moi un pays de
patricia rites et de niveau 1 c'est à
dire avec familles souches et des
héritages par le fils aîné et c'est donc
une poussée en fait de masculinisme en
fait en allemagne et le protestantisme
est de fait très
très hostile aux femmes c'est l'idée cdu
quand on lit le petit catéchisme de
lutter on voit le père qui vient qui
devient en fait le prêtre de sa famille
et le destin d'une femme c'est de
vénérer dieu à travers son mari la
mythologie la femme
type idéal du protestantisme c'est eve
qui est quand même le péché originel est
une menace réelle dans le sens et l'afad
dont ils ont la représentation c'est
l'équipe idéale au sens vd rien oui je
me suis mal exprimé mais c'est pas la
vierge marie voilà fait les vierge marie
c'est la mère du christ on le vénère de
la religion catholique à la religion
protestante aujourd'hui méfiez-vous dave
voilà c'est ça et donc ce procès santis
alors ça quand il est apparu en
allemagne il était si on peut dire
raccord
avec l'évolution familiale locale et
d'ailleurs quand on quand on voit la
façon dont l'allemagne c'est
alphabétisés on voit ainsi apparaître un
énorme écart
xviiie siècle entre les taux
d'alphabétisation des hommes et des
femmes il ya déséquilibre extraordinaire
et l'allemagne est un pays en fait qu'on
pourrait décrire si les féministes
veulent vraiment parler de patriarcat en
europe qu'elle tende de l'allemagne mais
ce protestantisme s'est étendue
vers la scandinavie sous la forme du
littéralisme
vers la france du sud sous la forme du
calvinisme plus tôt en angleterre sous
la forme du calvinisme aux états unis
donc et il était porteur de cette
idéologie pas de faire carle mais en ce
qui concerne en tout cas la scandinavie
et les
les pays anglo américain la religion
c'est trouver comment conflit en fait
avec avec le fond chasseurs cueilleurs
si on peut dire avec le fond égalitaire
donc et une tension qui a été créée et
en particulier parce que protestantisme
était aussi très progressiste sur le
plan éducatif c'était la stabilisation
qui allait tout le monde devait lire la
bible il compris les femmes sauf en
allemagne généralement au début donc à
cette tension dans les cultures
protestante de l'ouest qui a avoué et où
un féminisme de contestation à une
révolte mais quand on regarde je me
souviens à l'époque dans les années 70
les féministes du monde anglo américains
regardaient la france comme un pays
infernal parce que cette étape et où où
les femmes s'émancipent est sans qu'il y
ait de mouvements féminisme féministe
considéré comme sérieux à l'échelle du
monde anglo américain où cette heure où
il y avait une sorte d'émancipation
quand même à la base en bonne entente
donc c'était si on peut dire l'idéologie
du journal elle en fait duc qui avait
conquis le monde qui tempêtent contre
conquérir le monde est ce que vous dites
au fossé que en france oui ça se passe
bien il ya ça serait bien ça c'est là
c'est bien parce que les hommes les
frères les perles et mario vraiment ça
ne reposait pas un tel problème que les
femmes s'affranchissent pour faire quand
même
les femmes françaises ont eu le droit de
vote 50 ans après les néo zélandaise
comment vous l'expliquez vous quand même
quelques réticences oui mais si on veut
absolument mais dans ce cas là il faut
rentrer dans la mécanique générale du
système france sur les femmes avaient
leur lieu de pouvoir qui les
représentaient l'église d'une certaine
façon qui terrorisaient les
radicaux-socialistes donc il y avait une
sorte de tension dans les radios
socialiste parce que la loi qui donne le
droit de vote aux femmes en france elle
est votée très tôt à l'assemblée
nationale s'est laissé d'acteurs qui la
bloque et pour vous c'est parce que ils
ont peur que les faits relatés pour les
cathos vote pour les cathos voilà mais
d'un autre côté il faut rentrer dans ce
qu'on mettrait le roy ladurie
appellerait de l'histoire total c'est à
dire que vous ne pouvez pas dans
l'histoire de france simplement
extraire
l'histoire du droit de vote et j'ai du
retard des femmes françaises dans le
vert la france est aussi le pays qui le
premier dès la fin du xviiie siècle et
pleinement au 19e a commencé à pratiquer
le contrôle des naissances donc ce qui
suggère une dynamique complètement
différente des rapports de couple c'est
à dire qu'il ya parce que et dans bien
des cas d'ailleurs la technique de
contrôle des naissances
c'était même pas qui est interrompue
s'était même pas le préservatif
c'était en milieu paysan les femmes
envoyait alors mario grenier et puis je
n'ose pas dire l'expression qu'on
utilisait pour cette situation dévolu
station radical sur glace est jeune et
ce qui explique aussi la fréquence du
bordel en france qui est traité comme un
voyez il ya une dynamique générale de se
dépenser sur le plan de l'évolution de
la sexualité et de sa maîtrise avait un
siècle d'avancé sur tous les autres ça
aussi que quand on nous rebat les
oreilles ça j'en ai peut parler dans le
livre avec la libération sexuelle des
années 60 donc que vous traitez comme le
féminisme de deuxième vague qui arrive
avec les pilules 1 et avec la
légalisation de l'avortement en france
je le rappelle la fortement ses 75 la
pile ces 67 et et c'est vrai que les
femmes de la génération précédente
rigole quand on leur dit que les femmes
se sont libérés seulement à ce moment là
en tout cas les françaises disent
attention on n'a pas attendu les années
60 pour être des femmes libres
sexuellement non mais là la france a une
histoire là je ne peux pas prétendre
résoudre le problème et j'admets
volontiers que cette
tentative
patriarcale napoléonienne et caetera et
ce ne sont pas traitées dans lire j'ai
sauté deux époques anciennes oui et je
les résistances je suis parti dans
l'étude de l'évolution en france je suis
parti de l'immédiate après-guerre qu'une
famille a ses petites bourgeoises
conformisme y compris dans les milieux
prolétarien après la guerre mais il ya
toute cette soirée si vraiment on veut
l'étudier il faut le faire dans toute sa
complexité il faut bien voir que tout le
monde hommes et femmes au 19e siècle en
france et elle je dirais absent de super
mauvais jeu de mots dans un grand état
d'insécurité sexuelle puisque c'était
une époque où
il y avait aussi beaucoup de liberté de
moeurs il y avait aussi beaucoup
d'hommes tromper un autre sur des fous
rires balzac zola maupassant match
lorsque le bonne hauteur pour essayer de
se pénétrer de la complexité de la
période c'est beau passing et c'est pas
seulement dans les textes de loi et
qu'il faut qu'il faut le regarder on
peut regarder le code napoléon comme
l'effet d'une grande frayeur masculine
mais néanmoins vous expliquez bien aussi
si les pères
ont peur de laisser sortir leur leur
fille il ya des raisons c'est
qu'effectivement avant l'invention de la
pilule est de 500 c'est ce que vient le
coeur la j'appelle l'attitude enfants
gâtés du néo féminisme actuelle c'est à
dire que apparemment là la pilule et
plein d'autres moyens contraceptifs
modernes je dire je ne vais pas en faire
la liste actuellement
fait que les parents ne ne vivent pas
par le père et la mère dans un état de
frayeur non pas pour leurs enfants en
général mais pour leur fille dire on
parle toujours maintenant
avec horreur du double standard c'est un
des garçons qui ont le droit de sortir
et de couches et de sortir et de coucher
et défis contient mais il faut bien voir
que avant jeudi pour résumer la pilule
une fille qui était qui se retrouvaient
filles mères se retrouvait avec une vie
détruite j'avoue devenir un exemple
concret je t'assure que comme disait ma
mère toujours prenons un exemple au
hasard mois voilà donc je prends
l'exemple de mon arrière grand mère
anglaise
homosexuel notoire
avouez-le à cette époque qui était
rédactrice en chef de l'édition
anglaise de vogue au début des années 20
donc au sexuelle ces problèmes dans sa
vie non pas du tout était lié à son
homosexualité
mais au fait que avant d'avoir trouvé sa
voie elle avait couché avec un homme et
une fille et père fille mère enfin voyez
ma grand mère voilà c'était ça le
problème donc c'est un peu moyen il faut
quand même
il faut être capable de comprendre la
dureté du monde d'avant voyez le mot est
là justement quand on arrive au
féminisme d'aujourd'hui et
et qui nous dit mais
les femmes par exemple sont encore moins
bien payées que les hommes y compris en
france oui comment vous l'expliquez
alors d'abord je crois qu'il faut
lire dans le livre je note l'existence
de ce que j'appelle
sans doute d'obsession capillaire une
pellicule supérieur masculine
résiduelles associés que j'évalue à 4%
ce qui fait beaucoup pour quand on pense
en terme de domination des grands
appareils bureaucratiques économique et
de l'économie capitaliste qui est ancré
dans le truc des grandes écoles dans une
spécialisation des hommes dans les
sciences des mathématiques je ne lis pas
du tout l'existence de ça bon on voit
que pour une part cette télé culte est
en cours d'effritement je ne suis pas
certain qu'elle disparaîtra complètement
je ne il ya 4 % des hommes qui voient la
série sonny simplement l'important c'est
de savoir pourquoi cette chose existe
cette strate existe alors est-ce que
c'est par l'effet d'une volonté
masculine frénétique de domination des
femmes je ne crois pas ce que je dis
c'est que je reviens bon à l'hypothèse
de la très grande entrepôts l'ogre
américain de marguerittes mille surtout
mon livre on pourrait dire que c'est mon
livre est sous domination patriarcale
dans ses concepts qui disait que le
problème des hommes en fait ça c'était
avant l'émancipation m c'est un livre
qui date de l'immédiate après guerre le
problème des hommes c'est un reversement
de l'hypothèse freudienne absurde sur le
pont sur lequel des hommes souffraient
les femmes souffrent terriblement de ne
pas avoir un instrument entre les deux
hommes cet instrument dont montagne nous
disait que le fonctionnement était très
incertain d'aller du pénis voilà je
voulais faire et souffrirait d'un manque
de damas ça c'est les absurdités si
l'hypothèse de bahreïn mais
fondamentalement beaucoup plus raisonnée
et raisonnable s'est dit que un petit
garçon là il sait pas à quoi il sert en
fait c'est que c'est que les filles
elles savent qu'elles vont être capables
de faire des bébés auxquels savent elles
ont une possibilité de réalisation
a priori inscrits dans l'homme bon va
devoir essayer de comprendre et
d'apprendre qu'elle est de contribuer à
ce processus les contributions très
incertaine et donc bague retenue elle
interprète l'agitation des hommes à
travers l'histoire que ce soit dans la
fabrication d'outils la guerre tout ce
qui est bien et tout ce qui a deux
manches par un désir de compensation en
fait essayer de justifier son existence
il faut qu'il se réalise lui aussi oui
enfin je veux dire c'est que c'est
l'homme la condition humaine c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on veut réseau foula faut
s'occuper est encodé sur père du mieux
qu'on peut et est celle oms a produit un
surcroît d'activité alors ça ne veut pas
dire pour les pour les femmes émancipées
actuel qui maintenant existe socialement
tout à fait indépendamment de leur mari
grâce à l'éducation
avec le fait que pour tout ce qui n'est
pas cette pellicule supérieur maintenant
les femmes font plus d'études que les
hommes et les femmes accèdent tout à
fait à partie de l'anxiété masculine de
base que faire de sa vie tout à fait
indépendamment de l'homme qu'elle doive
et qu'elles ne doivent plus épouser mais
nous aurons l onglet les halls m elles
ont des problèmes mais elles ont elles
sont allées aux problèmes à mais il
reste toujours l'option enfants est
quand même importante et quand même
sympathique et que les hommes n'ont pas
donc les hommes sont deux situations
s'ils veulent faire quelque chose ils
n'ont pas vraiment le choix ça va être
pour ils peuvent devenir un sage à
l'abri du monde et ne rien faire ce qui
est déjà une performance en soi parce
que masculine ou non mais je veux dire
c'est la réussite sociale ou rien donc
voyez alors que les femmes sont donc le
la résistance qui existent dans la
société pour moi
ne vient pas des hommes mais c'est
quelque chose qui est intérieure aux
femmes c'est à dire c'est une
contradiction je dirais que des choses
sont
jamais apparus l'autre jour des
discussions avec un journaliste de la
montagne c'est que en fait
les les hommes on dirait en plaisantant
sont encore un peu mieux situés sur la
kz2 l'égalité ils sont un peu plus égaux
dans ce qui existe maintenant un quand
même voilà mais en fait les femmes sont
actuellement en un sens anthropologique
et métaphysique plus haut sur l'acte de
la liberté les femmes ont plus d'options
que les hommes dans la ville ces jo ce
qu'on ne voit jamais n'est toujours pas
non mais les hommes gagnent plus
d'argent etc en vérité les options de
vie d'une femme sont actuellement
beaucoup plus vastes que celles qui sont
ouvertes aux hommes c'est ça les
problèmes et pour vous les différences
de salaires qui à travail égal sont
quand même moins importante que ce qu'on
nous dit c'est de l'ordre de 8 ou 9 %
oui la sas était dûe à un ou deux ans
qu'on passe à faire des bébés ça va être
ça mais en plus ça c'est quand on mesure
dans des secteurs d'activité
particuliers et cetera et c'est le genre
de mesure qui nous retirera du champ de
notre perception le fait que en général
quand même les hommes sont à la fois
mieux représenté dans la pellicule
patrie dominant du dessous mais dans le
monde ouvrier en décomposition à suite
de la désindustrialisation etc les
hommes sont beaucoup plus durement
touchés bon j'ai pas dans le livre j'ai
pas voulu faire du tout 2 2 masculinisme
plaintif régressif
revendicative et serra je m'intéresse à
accepter aux hommes dans le bouquin
finalement mais depuis je me suis quand
même dit mais bon c'est vrai il ya les
familles monoparentales c'est des femmes
qui demandent le divorce ont-elles
raison ont-ils tort ne le saura jamais
mais les hommes qui ne sont plus là où
est ce qu'ils sont et puis chalet depuis
c'est pas dans le livre je suis allé
regarder je reste chercheurs mois jour
pour jour je regarde les sdf on regarde
les décès de sdf 85% donne sur les sdf
c'est des hommes c'est des célibataires
ou divorcés voyez donc ce n'est pas je
crois que fondamentalement le les balles
entendu en dehors du fait que sur le
fond je ne suis pas un idéologue je ne
tiens pas tellement
au delà d'un certain agacement
d'anthropologues je ne tiens pas
tellement à prendre parti mais la bonne
position méthodologique et métaphysique
c'est quand même si on part de cette
idée
que ce qui a fait le succès de l'espèce
humaine c'est la collaboration des
hommes et des femmes se quand leurs
enfants c'est pas la manif pour tout
cela un malade en parce que les
chasseurs cueilleurs
infanticide avortement abandon des
vieillards si nécessaire s'est passé par
le christianisme mais mais c'est que
quand même
la bonne position c'est la condition
humaine est difficile pour tous donc
donc maintenant ce qui est pleinement
apparent pour moi c'est qu'il ya deux
modalités d'une condition humaine qui
est difficile pour tous il ya la
variante masculine est pas toujours
facile variante t/min qui est pas
toujours facile mais bon quand on ne se
sent pas bien c'est la logique de
recherche du bouc émissaire est tout à
fait normal justement c'est là où est ce
que vous dites c'est pourquoi au fond il
ya aujourd'hui un mouvement féministe
qui ne se sent pas bien équilibrée spare
parts en cas de tagounit sme avec les
hommes vous nous dites au fond que les
femmes aujourd'hui une division du
travail toujours mais là pas oublier
qu'à obligatoires mais qui est ce qui
vient du fond des âges qui font que les
femmes travaillent plus volontiers dans
le tertiaire ou dans le soin au web et
aux enfants aux jeunes aux vieillards
aux malades dans les professions
médicales
dans le dans la fonction publique donc
elles sont toujours dans la gestion de
la maison au fond des eaux usées la wii
avec avec une différence qui montrent
que en fait eu de vraie capacité de
pouvoir c'est la justice aussi qui
maintenant en france dans l'autorité
dans l'autorité voilà les mêmes dans un
pays comme je donne les chiffres pour la
suède qui s'autoproclament bel sur un
jour la suède autres en guerre pour
défendre l'idéal féminin je ne sais pas
puisque la suède devient belliciste mais
même en suède la division sexuelle du
travail en suède les plombiers sont des
hommes les infirmières sont des
infirmières etc donc il ya quelque chose
qui ne bouge pas pour être vraiment quel
est donc il ya aujourd'hui cette idée j
pour vous il ya deux il ya des
différences nouvelle qui apparaissent
maintenant ça ça m'a vraiment intéressé
quand j'étudiais l'émancipation
l'homosexualité qui a été rendue
possible par l'émancipation des femmes
puisque les
sexualités c'étaient des hommes qui
persécutait des hommes le secteur des
féminines tout le monde s'en fichait est
en fait ce qui apparaît en tout cas dans
un contexte post chrétien c'est que
cette émancipation laisse apparaître
chez les hommes le maintien de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une homosexualité
exclusive
je pense que je me fais comprendre alors
que ce qui est caractéristique de la
période actuelle c'est une émergence
chez les jeunes femmes de la bisexualité
plus tôt donc on voit apparaître
nouvelles différences entre hommes et
femmes c'est pour ça c'est pour ça que
quand même on n'a même pas de choix là
nous au fond on n'a même pas de cette
option
j'y avais pas pensé mais effectivement
c'est c est alors fini il ya des études
donc c'est le noeud de parce que
pourquoi ils prospèrent ce nouveau
féministe antagonistes nous dit qu'au
fond ce sont ces femmes qui aujourd'hui
sont à peu près dans tous les domaines
et plus diplômées que les hommes et
depuis plus longtemps qu'on ne le croit
au fond sorte à ses 4 % d'hommes tout en
haut qui eux ne bougent pas qu'ils
résistent et au fond ce serait la lutte
des classes qui deviendrait un nouveau
féminisme et je croise je croise les
variables de classe et de sexe c'est ce
que j'appelle intersexualité généralisée
c'est une certaine malice puisque
l'intéressé sécurité sens à travers un
concept féministe et je distingue des
classes moyennes plutôt matrice entrées
et des classes supérieures plus tôt
patrice entrer mais je ne dis pas
je dis pas que la crasse est plus
importante que le sec je dis qu'il faut
avoir les deux pour comprendre ce qui se
passe mais quand même quand j'y pense
on va était depuis la sortie de ce livre
ce qui m'a frappé c'est à quel point
les féministes de cette idéologie etc
sont dans certains secteurs de la
société d'activité mais à quel point ce
n'est pas les femmes en général j'avais
distinguer les femmes des milieux
populaires on pourra aussi en dit ça y
est les femmes qui entrent dans cette
télé culte supérieur il ya un côté
vraiment petit bourgeois en fait dans
voulait dire que sur les cinq
institutions européennes y en a trois
qui sont dirigées par des femmes voilà
ils ne sont pas est en fait en femme les
femmes qui arrivent à ces niveaux là le
public de troisième vague où le néo
féminisme désigné victime morte à
gonesse aux victimes un nom elles n'ont
évidemment
rien à faire voilà mais quand même en
réfléchissant ce qui me frappe dans ce
féminisme antagonistes c'est
le livre n'est pas là dessus en fait
vraiment c'était c'est ce qui m'a donné
envie de travailler sur l'histoire des
femmes mais sa toute petite partie du
bouquin le tout la sortie du livre s'est
faite sur ce sujet parce que c'est là
que ça grave c'est là que ça fait mal et
j'étais forcé dit quand même qui a pas
eu de prêtres patriarcat dans un pays
comme le nôtre qui moi me fait plaisir
je suis tombé là que j'ai même sabot
lancer mon arrière grand père avait
esclavagisés mais mon arrière grand mère
oui c'est ça mais en fait pour moi
c'était dans mon livre cd précision
méthodologique
d essayer de comprendre l'émancipation
des femmes en pratique la légende du néo
féminisme nenê n'est pas vraiment mon
sujet et en fait depuis que le livre est
sorti je me suis mis à réfléchir
vraiment sur le néo féminisme mais est
ce qui me frappe c'est à quel point bon
jeu défini comme une idéologie au sens
gramscien loger dans certaines
catégories sociales eux femmes
universitaires
petites brochures etc mais ce qui me
frappe c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai vu beaucoup de
femmes vraiment émancipée qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ça c'est à quel point ce
antagonismes anti masculin et régressif
c'est d'ailleurs à quel point ils
manifestent finalement chez ces porteuse
est porteuse et c'est porteur d'ailleurs
puisque j'ai découvert aussi le jeune
mâle féministe aussi tu penses que je
suis un vieux con rica peut-être bien
raison à quel point ces régressive parce
que c'est typiquement la vraiment si
passion c'est arrivé à se penser soi
même indépendamment de l'eau de l'autre
sexe etc et en fait ça évoque
terriblement une incapacité à se
détacher du problème masculin c'est à
dire que le féminisme antagonismes et
régressive parce qu'il est implicitement
masculinistes siècle parce qu'il prend
les hommes beaucoup trop au sérieux
c'est ça qui me frappe pourra-t-il de ma
génération parce que je sais à quel
point on était féministe naturels ccan
fait ses études c'est en fait je trouve
ce dès au féminisme assez insultant pour
les femmes oui je sais pas oui on peut
effectivement le voir comme ça c'est à
dire qu'au fond on a construit d'après
ce que vous dites une image de l'homme
asservissant esclavagisme donc à la
limite mais très puissant oui c'est n'a
pas eu cette puissance là d'après ce que
je dirai en fait mon arrière grand père
n'était pas aussi puissant que le
croient les féministes d'aujourd'hui oui
mais s'il obéissait à sa femme sur plein
de dans plein de domaines damas est ce
que vous me direz vous les camps quand
un type ça c'est un truc d' analyse sur
les interactions sociales
si un type vous dit sur vous même ou sur
quelque chose quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas demandé et qui est aberrant et qui
n'a aucun rapport avec la réalité en
fait il est en train de vous parler de
lui il est en train de vous dire ce
qu'il a dans le crown est en fait les
néo féministes ou dans le crâne cette
idée absurde que les hommes sont
supérieurs c'est ça le problème est
qu'il faut les détruire ces régressif ce
sera le mot de la fin enfin de la fin de
cette émission est correct ma faim c'est
la fin de cette émission il reste ce
livre où en sont elles une esquisse de
l'histoire des femmes ça vienne paraître
au seuil merci emmanuel todd devoir
passer de toute cette émission avec nous
merci de l'avoir suivi à rendez-vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]